[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
janna pareigis guten abend was heute
beim sport wichtiges passiert ist das
erfahren sie von arbeitnehmern ein
shooter formel aber vor allem schauen
wenn dieser sendung auf die aktuelle
lage im ukraine contract
wohnblöcke kindergärten krankenhäuser
russland setzt seine angriffe fort die
un bestätigen mehr als 550 zivile opfer
tatsächlich sei die zahl wohl aber
deutlich höher
auch der propaganda krieg geht weiter
vor dem un-sicherheitsrat wiederholt
moskau den vorwurf die usa und die
ukraine wollten bio waffen herstellen
und die korona zahlen in deutschland
steigen wieder die lage sei objektiv
viel schlechter als die stimmung war und
gesundheitsminister lauterbach
die gefechten der ukraine weitet sich
immer weiter aus nach angaben der un
liegen dabei glaubwürdige berichte über
mehrere fälle vor in denen die russische
armee streumunition in bewohnten
gebieten eingesetzt haben soll das wäre
völkerrechtswidrig guten leinhos und
christoph distel über die lage der krieg
rückt immer tiefer ins zentrum der
ukraine vor erstmals wird die
industriestadt libro angegriffen aus
einer schuhfabrik wird in sekunden ein
ruine auch ein kindergarten und ein
apartmenthaus werden schwer getroffen
bisher war die eine million einwohner
stadt von luftangriffen verschont
geblieben
alina ist fassungslos sie war erst vor
wenigen tagen aus harkins vermeintlich
sichere libro geflüchtet
das gab ihr eine andere welt wie der
umzug auf einen anderen planeten dann
heute morgen wieder bomben und sofort
kommt die panik hoch und diese gedanken
ich muss wieder weg und wieder packen
und sehen wie wir hier rauskommen und
so ist das im landesinneren gelegene
thunebro wohl nur eine zwischenstation
auf alina suche nach sicherheit nach
halb elf zurück kann sie nicht es wird
ständig beschossen und die angreifer
sind der stadtgrenze schon gefährlich
nahe
die russischen soldaten stehen nur noch
rund 900 meter von hier gerade kann man
hören wie sie auf unsere stellungen
schießen
die lage in der stadt ist katastrophal
die u bahn stationen sind für viele
dauerhaftes notquartier vor einer woche
ist auch nastia mit ihrer familie hier
runter gezogen und gleich krank geworden
ich sehne mich nach hause und dass ich
endlich wieder gut schlafen kann und
dass das alles hier möglichst schnell
vorbeigeht
am tag 16 dieses krieges weite russlands
armee ihre offensive deutlich aus zwei
ukrainische militärflughäfen im westen
werden angegriffen der belagerungsring
um die hauptstadt und mehrere vororte
ein weiteres mal enger gezogen
russische panzer konvois rücken näher an
kiefern auf routen die in den
vergangenen tagen das ziel schwere
luftangriffe waren
und aus den zerstörten orten fliehen die
menschen in die hauptstadt manche
berichten völlig verstört von
begegnungen mit russischen soldaten
sie blieben einfach stimmen sagten kein
wort gar nichts es war als seien sie aus
stein
zunehmend verzweifelte wird die
situation in den städten mario pohl und
wollen nova
hunderttausende zivilisten sind hier
seit zehn tagen eingeschlossen immer
mehr menschen flüchten inzwischen nach
moldawien das nachbarland hatten den
letzten tagen 300.000 ukraine
aufgenommen
und in der ukraine ist für uns katrin
eigendorf kathrin wenn man die angriffe
sie kriegt man den eindruck dass sich
der krieg jetzt immer stärker gegen die
zivilbevölkerung richtet stimmt das ja
wir werden hier im hintergrund gerade
eine ansprache des ukrainischen
präsidenten an die bevölkerung werde
über lautsprecherwagen
wird in der stadt und er sagte an diesem
16 tag des krieges sehen wir wirklich
dass die russen darauf zielen immer
weiter die zivilbevölkerung anzugreifen
das tun sie indem sie städte wie mario
pohl ein single verhindern dass dort
humanitäre hilfe reinkommt die leute
haben dort keine lebensmittel mehr es
gehen die medikamente aus das gleiche
ziel verfolgen die russen auch mit kiew
auch hier steht kurz davor ein getingelt
zu werden und immer mehr sehen wir eben
auch angriffe auf
kinderkrankenhäuser jetzt in mikro den
angriff auf einem kindergarten also die
zivilbevölkerung ist hiernach jens kies
aussage ganz klar das ziel der russen er
spricht von terror und wenn man sich das
anguckt diese lage viel putin
anscheinend ganz bewusst darauf die
zivilbevölkerung hier immer mehr in
angst und schrecken und terror zu
versetzen das hat natürlich auch damit
zu tun dass das dass die russen hier
sehr großen widerstand erleben von der
armee aber auch von der bevölkerung und
das ist eine art von ja die
moralisierung der bevölkerung auf die
ihr abzielt aus der ukraine hat den
eigendorf danke
militärisch aber ist russland der
ukraine überlegen trotz oder gerade
deswegen greifen unabhängig von den
ukrainischen reservisten auch weitere
menschen aus der zivilbevölkerung zu den
waffen sowie in einem ort nahe der bella
russischen grenze der freie journalist
am gentzel war dort
wir sind unterwegs im norden der ukraine
kommen vorbei an einem checkpoint bürger
haben posten bezogen gegen die russen
die namen ihrer stadt sollen wir lieber
nicht nennen aus sicherheitsgründen wir
stehen hier vor einem sogenannten blog
post das heißt das sind solche
kontrollpunkte selbstverteidigungs
punkte wo sich zivilisten aus dem ort
versammelt haben und versuchen quasi
widerstand oder soll man sagen
verteidigungskräfte zu mobilisieren wo
läuft ja ist 53 jahre alt und eigentlich
fahrer jetzt ist er im krieg mit seinem
jagdgewehr das
ist eine simson 1949 er baujahr mit
patronen gott bewahre falls irgend ein
russe kommt werden wir schießen was kann
man sonst tun wir müssen unsere leute
verteidigen
als sie mit ihnen ins gespräch kommen
bitten die männer deutschland und den
westen um unterstützung
wir brauchen schlaf ausrüstung
schutzwesten und helme sie sehen ja
unter welchen bedingungen hier hier
arbeiten wir sind freiwillige bekommen
kein geld wir brauchen nachtsichtgeräte
und auch warmes schuhwerk
noch am morgen habe es einen luftangriff
gegeben im nachbarort sei eine rakete
eingeschlagen
ein paar kilometer weiter in einer
schule hat das kommando der örtlichen
selbstverteidigung quartier bezogen hier
lernen ukrainische männer wie man mit
einer kalaschnikow umgeht
die ausbildung verläuft super ohne
stress der trainer ist super erklärt
alles ruhig ohne zu schreien mental ist
auch alles bestens wir sind sehr gut
eingestellt
die lage im grenzgebiet zu belarus
erzählen sie uns sie spitzt sich immer
weiter zu
während sich also auf ukrainischer seite
die zivilbevölkerung bewaffnet stoßen
zur russischen seite offenbar kämpfer
aus dem nahen osten
so spricht sich russlands präsident
putin für die entsendung wie er es nennt
freiwilliger kämpfer in den don budge
colonia teil mit einem blick nach
russland
medaillen für die helden in moskau
besucht russlands verteidigungsminister
sergej schoigu die verletzten des
russischen kriegsschiffs der nicht krieg
genannt werden darf wer informationen
über die zahl der toten und verletzten
verbreitet macht sich nach wie vor
strafbar
derweil isoliert sich das land weiter
russlands generalstaatsanwaltschaft wird
berichtet blockiert nun auch den zugang
zu instagram alle meter plattformen
gelten fortan als extremistisch ein
verheerender schritt für viele russische
unternehmen die stimmung unter vielen
moskauern angespannt
ich spüre panik zukunftsangst aber das
alles wird noch verarbeitet
unterstützen sie die militäroperationen
er nicht ich glaube dass da jemand
eigene spiele spielt eigene pläne
verfolgt wir wissen doch zu 99 prozent
nicht was da überhaupt passiert
ich war gegen den einmarsch da sie nun
aber einmarschiert sind muss man bis zum
ende gehen eine andere lösung gibt es
nicht
der kreml heute der belarussische
machthaber alexander lukaschenko
wiederholt die sicht des kreml auf eine
angeblich aggressive ukraine putin
stimmt zu und nickt
was die gespräche mit der ukraine angeht
also sie gehen praktisch täglich weiter
es gibt gewisse positive tendenzen sagen
mir unsere verhandler
seit gestern abend ist gerhard schröder
in moskau seine frau postete ein foto
über den aufenthalt dort offenbar hat
der altkanzler gespräche mittler die mir
putin geführt
lassen wir das einschätzen von unserem
russland korrespondenten axel sturm der
derzeit hier ist axel welche rolle kann
altkanzler schröder spielen bei
vermittlungsbemühungen
naja gerhard schröder kann natürlich
mitbringen was andere staats und
regierungschefs nicht mitbringen können
er kann eine andere dialogform
mitbringen eine andere gesprächskultur
und der grund dafür liegt in einer
jahrzehntealten freundschaft zwischen
ihm und dem russischen staatspräsidenten
gerhard schröder bekleidet zurzeit zwei
wichtige posten in der russischen
energiewirtschaft einem für einen
dritten ist er nominiert er und seine ex
frau haben zwei russische weisen kinder
adoptiert dabei soll wladimir putin
geholfen haben und bei seinem
sechzigsten und bei seinem siebzigsten
geburtstag bei putin persönlich gast
eine sogenannte männerfreundschaft
könnte man sagen und das kann natürlich
eine brücke schlagen zu einem anderen
dialog vielleicht auch zu einem dialog
in dem eine möglichkeit gefunden werden
kann in dem wladimir putin sein gesicht
wahren kann wenn es zum beispiel um
themen wie eine waffenruhe geht dank
versteuern
seit tagen wird russland den usa vor in
der ukraine biologische waffen zu
entwickeln auf initiative russlands hat
sich heute der un sicherheitsrat damit
beschäftigt der westen vermutet russland
wolle mit dieser behauptung nur ablenken
und plane möglicherweise selbst
massenvernichtungswaffen der ukraine
krieg einzusetzen und die sitzung des un
sicherheitsrates hat für uns new york
johannes hano verfolgt johannes da ging
es ja wirklich hoch her
ja ich glaube das ist eine neue
eskalationsstufe gezündet wurde der
russische botschafter hat monströse
vorwürfe erhoben die usa und die ukraine
würden biowaffen labore gemeinsam
betreiben um dort an viren und bakterien
zu forschen die dann so modifiziert
werden könnten dass sie nur slawische
menschen treffen und das sollte dann
über zugvögel und
pads also fledermäuse eingesetzt werden
richtung russland und er hat auch
gleichzeitig dann sich an die europäer
gericht gesagt passt mal auf das könnte
auch ganz gefährlich für euch werden das
hörte sich fast wie eine drohung an
beweise ist er schuldig geblieben es gab
dann die un die gesagt hat nein es gibt
überhaupt keine beweise für so etwas und
auch die amerikanische regierung hat
dementiert dass es solche labore gibt
natürlich gebe es medizinische labore da
würde daran geforscht werden zur
gefahrenabwehr wie in jedem anderen land
auch und das würde man auch unterstützen
aber das ganze sei eine große
desinformationskampagne in die gleiche
kerbe schlug auch präsident beiden kurz
vorher er machte dann auch noch mal klar
dass man neue sanktionen auf den weg
bringt die meistbegünstigungsklausel
soll entzogen werden das prost an in
zukunft mehrere oder höhere zölle zahlen
muss aber eines muss man glaube ich ganz
klar sagen der krieg findet längst nicht
mehr in der ukraine statt sondern es ist
ein informationskrieg geworden in der
ganzen welt der sich in unseren köpfen
abspielen soll johannes hano danke nach
new york herr neben den usa will auch
die eu weitere sanktionen gegen russland
verabschieden sie könnten laut
französischen präsidenten unbegrenzten
ausmaßes werden nichts ist verboten
nichts ist tabu sagte marko nachdem bei
ihm in versailles heute der informelle
gipfel der eu staats und
regierungschefinnen und chefs zu ende
ging worauf sich das alles gereinigt
wurde berichtet anne gellinek
es war eine unerwartet lange nacht für
die europäischen staats und
regierungschefs und chefinnen im
prunkvollen spiegelsaal von schloss
versailles bis halb drei heute morgen
verhakt sich europa darüber ob man der
ukraine angesichts des krieges ein
express eu-beitritt gewähren kann die
antwort am morgen nein
ich verstehe die emotionen und die
erwartungen der ukraine aber wir im
europäischen rat haben eine starke und
klare antwort gefunden
sie lautet die jahrelange beitritts
prozedur muss eingehalten werden so die
mehrheit die bayerischen regierungschefs
dagegen enttäuscht
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass die ukraine
jetzt den status des beitrittskandidaten
bekommt aber das ist eine
maximalforderung die heute nicht möglich
war
stattdessen stellen die europäer neue
militärhilfen in aussicht 500 millionen
euro für die lieferung von waffen und
ausrüstung an die ukraine doppelt so
viel wie bisher vorgesehen bei der
diskussion über einen sofortigen stopp
von energielieferungen aus russland
bleibt deutschland hart zusammen mit
österreich italien und ungarn es ist
eine bewusste begründete und
nachvollziehbare entscheidung dass wir
jedenfalls von unserer seite aus die
importe die wir heute in dem bereich der
energie haben in europa nicht einstellen
werden was wir immer machen werden ist
uns so schnell wie möglich aus dieser
abhängigkeit heraus zu bewegen er gibt
sie von der site soll ein signal der
europäischen einheit richtung russland
senden die schwierigen gespräche zeigen
aber auch dass die spannungen innerhalb
europas zu nehmen je länger der krieg
dauert
und seit beginn des krieges sind nach
angaben der vereinten nationen mehr als
zweieinhalb millionen menschen aus der
ukraine geflohen seit tagen werden
spenden gesammelt auch gestern beim
spenden abend mit markus lanz der
aktuelle stand 95,4 millionen euro wenn
sie den menschen weiterhelfen und
spenden wollen dann können sie das beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe tun die
bahn de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf 0 hilfe ukraine alle infos
auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190
und mehr zur lage können sie in einem
zdf spezial sehen direkt im anschluss an
diese sendung der titel krieg in europa
große angriff auf die ukraine und der
krieg beschäftigt auch hier in
deutschland viele menschen sehr schauen
wir uns das im aktuellen
zdf-politbarometer an guten abend
matthias fornoff hallo was halten die
befragten von den sanktionen gegen
russland die wirtschaftlichen
strafmaßnahmen gegen russland die finden
große zustimmung bei den befragten
vielen gehen sie so gar nicht weit genug
soll deutschland die gas und öl importe
aus russland stoppen auch wenn das hier
zu versorgungsengpässen führt eine
mehrheit von 55 prozent sagt ja 39
prozent sind dagegen darunter
mehrheitlich die anhänger von fdp und
linke
drei viertel sind in sorge vor einem
noch größeren krieg und
waffenlieferungen
67 prozent fanden die bisherigen
lieferungen richtig schwere waffen wie
zum beispiel panzer zu liefern nehmt
eine klare mehrheit aber ab und wir
kommen jetzt in der krise die
ampelkoalition an regierung und kanzler
machen ihre arbeit gut das sagen 75
beziehungsweise
73 prozent mit deutlicher steigerung
gegenüber der bewertung vor zwei wochen
+11 und plus 8 prozentpunkte in der
krise also viel zustimmung für die
regierenden zum schluss noch ein blick
auf corona dass die meisten
schutzmaßnahmen zum 20 märz weg feind
finden 50 prozent richtig und 47 prozent
nicht das ist richtig sagen zwei drittel
der jüngeren bei über 60 jährigen sind
es nur 36 prozent je älter also die
befragten desto größer die vorsicht
danke für die zahl mit neun auf und das
ausführliche politbarometer gibt es wie
immer im heute-journal ab 22 uhr 10 und
auch in unserer zdf heute app finden sie
alle zahlen und umfragewerte zb die zu
den beliebtesten politikerinnen und
politikern deutschland
in gut einer woche sollen also corona
beschränkungen gelockert werden und dass
gesundheitsminister lauterbach warnt
aber davor zu glauben die pandemie sei
vorüber die situation sei weiterhin
kritisch sagte er bei der gemeinsamen
pressekonferenz mit dem robert koch
institut nach dem rückgang der
neuinfektionen im februar steigen sie
seit einigen tagen wieder das rkw meldet
heute
252 1836 neuinfektionen
249 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
kurven 19 binnen eines tages aus berlin
frank buchwald
corona für viele die pandemie ihren
schrecken verloren der minister aber
bleibt besorgt das virus sei noch lange
nicht besiegt wir können nicht zufrieden
sein mit einer situation wo 200 bis 250
menschen jeden tag sterben und es macht
mir große sorge die lage ist objektiv
viel schlechter als die stimmung eine
gute woche noch dann laufen die meisten
corona regeln aus dann stehen die länder
in der verantwortung sie können den
sogenannten hot spots eigene maßnahmen
verhängen um lokale ausbrüche
einzudämmen denn nach wie vor kranken
viel zu viele menschen schwören cupid
und nach wie vor sterben auch zu viele
menschen an dieser erkrankung und
dafür vorher leiden noch viele menschen
langzeitfolgen von kogit longo wird das
ist nicht nur atemnot jördis frommholz
chefärztin einer reha-klinik schildert
fälle aus ihrer praxis ich erinnere mich
an die 35 jährige mutter mit zwei
kindern kann im erstklässler als
vielleicht die hausaufgaben vorlesen sie
kann ihn aber nicht bei der lösung
helfen weil sie leider in den inhalt gar
nicht versteht der 25 jährige student
muss leider wieder anfangen die
grundrechenarten zu lernen weil auch das
vergessen hat gemeinsame botschaft der
mediziner impfung hilft die gefahren der
krankheit ungleich höher als mögliche
imf risiken erst recht angesichts
möglicher neuer virus variieren
zurück zur normalität das soll so
langsam für die schulen gelten die
kultusministerkonferenz hat sich darauf
geeinigt dass in der schule nach und
nach keine maske mehr getragen werden
muss bis spätestens mai sollen dann auch
die regelmäßigen tests und die
quarantäne der vergangenheit angehören
nach zwei jahren pandemie sollten kinder
und jugendliche im sommer wieder einen
normalen schulbetrieb erleben
der saudiarabische blogger reif batterie
ist mit ende seiner zehnjährigen
haftstrafe freigelassen worden das
bestätigte börries ehefrau die in kanada
lebt bei über 20 14 wegen beleidigung
des islams zu zehn jahren haft und 1000
peitschenhieben verurteilt worden
blicken wir jetzt auf die aufarbeitung
der flutkatastrophe in rheinland pfalz
die entscheidende frage ist ja warum die
bevölkerung im aartal nicht rechtzeitig
und ausreichend gewarnt wurde heute
abend sagt dazu die jetzige
bundesfamilienministerin eines spiegel
aus sie war damals im juli 20 21
rheinland-pfälzische umweltministerin
und stellvertretende ministerpräsidentin
und steht wegen ihres verhaltens während
der katastrophe in der kritik susanne
gelhard
andere spiegel als rheinland-pfälzische
umweltministerin an der chat protokolle
mit ihrem pressesprecher zeigen nun dass
sie am morgen nach der flut vor allem um
ihre eigenen darstellung besorgt war
das play game das heißt
schuldzuweisungen könnte sofort losgehen
ich traue es roger gemeint ist
innenminister lewentz zu dass er sagt
die katastrophe hätte verhindert werden
können oder wäre nicht so schlimm wenn
wir als umweltministerium früher gewarnt
hätten ein untersuchungsausschuss des
rheinland pfälzischen landtags
rekonstruiert seit wochen die genauen
abläufe am abend ist eine spiegel
geladen um ihre rolle zu klären
das was bisher bekannt ist es schon
erschreckend wenn man sich mehr sorgt um
sein eigenes image als um das leid der
menschen vor ort sie war nicht in der
lage telefon in die hand zu nehmen und
mal sich zu informieren bei der
präsidentin ihres amtes über die
dramatische situation
die grünen in rheinland-pfalz nehmen
eine spiegel in schutz die bundesspitze
jedoch ist alarmiert ich gehe davon aus
dass sie im untersuchungsausschuss des
rheinland pfälzischen landtags an diesem
freitag alle offenen fragen beantworten
wird sollte es dem
untersuchungsausschuss gelingen
politische versäumnisse von frau spiegel
nachzuweisen dann würde man sich
sicherlich fragen ob frau spiegel
angesichts dieser dramatischen halten
sie die wir im letzten jahr im aartal
gesehen haben als
bundesfamilienministerin weiter amtieren
kann um 19 uhr 30 soll die befragung von
einem spiegel im mainzer landtag
beginnen
nun kommen wir zum sport norbert
wirtschaftsverbund hat ihr einen neuen
präsidenten bernd neuendorf hat die wahl
gewonnen und zwar sehr deutlich der 60
jährige will einen neuanfang im größten
nationalen sportfachverband der welt zu
neuanfang gehört auch silke sinning die
den umstrittenen dfb funktionär reiner
koch verdrängt
herzlichen dank für ihr vertrauen die
sportwissenschaftlerin hat eine
zeitenwende eingeläutet mit 163 zu 68
stimmen haben die delegierten sich klar
für sich entschieden und für einen
neuanfang rainer koch scheidet nach 15
jahren aus dem dfb-präsidium aus deshalb
lautet meine erste und wichtigste
botschaft der fußball muss wieder im
mittelpunkt stehen nicht die querelen an
der spitze des verbandes bernd neubaus
amtszeit dauert drei jahre es gibt viel
zu tun im dfb seine mannschaft steht und
er ist stolz dass sie weiblicher
geworden ist
zu den paralympics drei weitere
medaillen für das deutsche team die
biathletinnen lin katzmaier und leonie
walter holen zusammen mit ihren geist
silber und bronze und im riesenslalom
erkämpft andrea rothfuß den dritten
platz auf dem podest
auch bei ihren fünften paralympics
gewinnt die 32-jährige aus freudenstadt
mindestens eine medaille wenn ich
irgendwas für unmöglich gehalten hätte
dann genau das damit hat andrea rothfuß
ihre herausragende edelmetall sammlung
um die vierzehnte paralympische medaille
erweitert
ohne schießfehler gewinnt die 15 jährige
lin katzmaier bei ihrem vierten start in
peking mit ihrem guide florian baumann
ihre vierte medaille über die 12,5
kilometer distanz ist nur die ukrainerin
schiwkow war um hauchdünne 3,6 sekunden
schneller als die deutsche dritte wird
mit ihrem guide termin strecker leonie
walter die heute ebenfalls in peking
ihre vierte medaille gewinnt
eine deutsche fußball-legende ist tot
einer der weltmeister von 74 und ikone
der frankfurter eintracht jürgen
grabowski starb im alter von 77 jahren
sein größter moment mit dem wm pokal
1974 der mittelfeldmann verdrängt auf
den rechten flügel aber zu wichtig um
nicht zu spielen sein tor gegen schweden
im viertelfinale die legendäre
frankfurter flügelzange mit bernd
hölzenbein war geboren vier jahre zuvor
bei der wm in mexiko noch als bester
einwechselspieler der welt gelobt dass
gefühle nicht und dann jeder spieler
will die national hin er will am anfang
dabei seine führungsfigur bei eintracht
frankfurt bekannt für glänzende technik
und dribbelkünste zweimal
dfb-pokalsieger
doch beim größten internationalen
triumph den gewinn des uefa-cups 1980
verletzt auf der bank zuletzt
gesundheitlich angeschlagen bleibt
jürgen grabowski doch anders im
gedächtnis
[Applaus]
morgen kommen mehr wolken auf aber nicht
überall wo und wo nicht das zeigt ihn
gleich ist intelli das heute-journal
läuft um 22 uhr 10 mit christian sievers
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gesamte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter heute gab es viel
sonnenschein das sehen wir hier auf
unserem satelliten film aber von
südwesten her kamen schon die ersten
schleierwolken ins land gezogen und es
wird schon in der nacht deutlich mehr
werden da gibt es sogar ganz im westen
etwas regen ansonsten aber ist es
weiterhin auf geklagt mit einem
kräftigen südostwind im osten wird es
eine kalte temperaturen bis minus 45
grad und minus acht grad nach südosten
hin deutlich milder im westen plus acht
grad morgen im tagesverlauf dann im
südwesten deutschlands überhaupt in der
westhälfte generell viele wolken nach
osten deutlich sonniger und auch
richtung bayern viel sonnenschein bei
höchsten temperaturen von sieben grad im
vogtland oder an der ostsee deutlich
milder nach westen mit 16 grad am
niederrhein und auch am oberrhein die
nächsten tage ändern sich die wolken es
gibt etwas mehr regen von südwesten her
am sonntag sonst aber sonnige abschnitte
bei neun bis 17 grad und vor allem am
dienstag wird es zwar wärmer aber
deutlich mehr regen ein schöner abend